hello and welcome to a brand new episode
of not too deep I'm your host grace
Helbig
we have Joel McHale here with us you
know him from says soup even though he
doesn't really want to talk about that
you also know him from community you
know him from his newest stand-up
special that's available for all of you
and your ears and your eyes to watch you
also will know that he loves swords and
knives and all of that fun stuff just
like a normal adult does he also was
part of a rowing team that used to make
all the guys shave their heads and take
the hair and put it into a pillow very
normal things on this episode of not too
deep with Joel McHale ever in the mood
for a great tasting beer but not the
buzz that comes with it
enter Brooklyn breweries special effects
a delicious flavorful brand-new brew
that happens to be non-alcoholic special
effects is not just for folks who don't
drink alcohol it's for anyone who wants
to do more with their days and nights so
head to Brooklyn Brewery comm slash
special effects for more info and to see
where you can pick up a six-pack or two
near you where are the dogs and why
aren't they here the dogs this is my
biggest disappointment of you walking in
this room I said goodbye tonight that
was just walk down said goodbye guys
because it's beanbag beanbag and cowboy
and cowboy and and the third one well
Harry is he's elusive okay but elusive
in like this is just like a dog in the
streets that you guys he can take any
form okay he's a shape-shifting cotone
do tell yay that's how I know it's a
little white dog and he is not he's like
the doc from Back to the Future yeah
okay he's got his own ideas and he has
no time for the beanbag cowboy
shenanigans beanbag and cowboy seem like
they're built perfectly for Instagram
they work they have really helped me
monitor me I have a dog and that's like
her sole purpose is like when I'm out of
content ideas I just turn it on her
let her do her work yeah and people
think I have a soul and our have empathy
yeah other beings because of these dogs
it balances you out compassion
my wife just talked well she didn't talk
me out of it but she stonewalled me on
getting another dog oh so you're a dog
person so if you know no okay cat person
actually really yeah no cats no I love
cats but my wife's allergic so uh no I
would I would get nine dogs really just
[ __ ] everywhere
yeah well the the two that are primarily
featured on your Instagram are their the
show durable they are and one of them is
very crazy and aggressive which bag
yeah the French Bulldog yes yeah he like
that's my favorite I follow a ton of
French Bulldog like a countess girl you
know I went through a big face and then
I feel like bad if I unfollow them
because I know that there's a human on
the other side that's like managing this
account after you unfollow accounts not
that often to be very fair yeah maybe
like one or two because they're boring
or because they've said something you
don't like I don't know who the person
isn't like I'm not that I don't know who
that person is anymore like I literally
don't know who this person is that I
started fun to call why you'd follow
them in the first no and that's why I
unfollow is that I don't remember I'm
sure it was like a late night being like
yeah here take it [ __ ] it show me your
account and you're okay with that
somewhere somewhere in this world yes
person when I just got him followed by
grace Helbig well as far as I know they
don't get the notifications they're
gonna know the very you blame the
algorithm I had no choice no idea it's
been accidentally on following a lot of
people in my feed I don't like Twitter
for a while was having me follow people
and unfollow people that I had no choice
in well it did my crazy you're not crazy
cuz I think it did this thing at one
point that it I don't know if it still
does where it would suggest people in
your feed that it would think that you
might like but it would come up as if
you're already following them cuz that
happened to me too that I was like when
the [ __ ] did I follow this like chef
celebrity but I don't really know it
alls really if you think about our plan
everyone's like it's gonna be 16 billion
people buy and it's really it'll be 60
million people in 25 years and 8 billion
of them will be celebrity chefs easily
if we're lucky but they'll have nothing
to cook with if you're a chef you're
like why am I going into this into
cooking for the fame for the fame for
the television shows do you think what
do you guys see how to be doing
otherwise I like how you say his name
that's how you say Yeti
Guy Fieri I'm giving him so much credit
yeah
I'm those flame tattoos going up his his
lower arms how would we know how to wear
sunglasses on the back of our neck if we
didn't have good right how would we know
what a Hawaiian shirt with it's always
black and orange frosted tips have never
been so frosted oh man it seems I hear
he's a very nice man yeah I never met
Sam I mean it's amazing he's alive for
the amount of water that he uses but I
that's what I eat so it's perfect course
is there anyone that you follow online
that's like hate not hate follow but
like that you're obsessed with following
that like is a lot like I don't hate
bird graveyard on Instagram that's a
wonderful what is that
it's just bird scooters being knocked
over like Adam like no no bird and like
the lime scooters and anything like that
Pete like there'll be a line of 100 and
so we're just tipping them all over
[ __ ] in rivers it's not good for the
environment or for the company yeah and
then there's a POV thing called POV
videos on Instagram that I they're all
terrifying videos of people like on
mountain bikes and then my and then on
what are you going reddit hold my beer
is pretty much yeah that's a great way
and then hold my feeding tube is rough
what is that for real yeah
I mean it is dark because it's it's all
the hole all the things that hold my
peers like we can't show that it's
because a person was terribly injured or
killed and then it comes up and I'm like
yeah no I follow drunk people doing
things dummies doing things people doing
things like workout fails stuff like
that yeah it's so it is weird because
some of those people that'll be like
that's what they will be known for for
the rest of their lives at their funeral
it will be brought up yeah that while
trying to benchpress 390 pounds their
pectoral muscles snapped yeah and we got
it on camera we have it and now it's
yeah well I mean David after dentist
will only be David after dentist I so
years ago I was at an Internet
convention in Boston like right after
David after dentist site came out and it
was with basically just memes walking
everywhere like the guy that made
keyboard cat was there and he was like
you know the Pied Piper of everyone
being like Jessica made keyboard cat and
I my friend and I sat in on this like
the opening whatever and we turned
around and David after Dennis was just
sitting behind us with his dad and we
were freaking the [ __ ] like if Leonardo
DiCaprio was sitting next to David yeah
how are your teeth man how's it going
no the sad part about those accounts is
that they're private so you have to
request permission to follow them so
it's one of those things you go yeah
yeah I want their approval I want to be
I want to be in I did that was Snooper
with oh it's newb is private yeah he's
got like 16 million followers yeah
everyone but he just wants you know this
is not free okay so you've been super
busy you know you're special just came
out thank you for mentioning it yeah
how'd that go this is his first one this
is my first one very cool took me you
know 16 years to get it together
has this been something in the works for
that long has this been something like
over the last couple years here like I
actually want to do this I finally felt
like I had
good enough jokes to be down yeah for a
while I was like I don't know if this
will I don't I just wasn't comfortable
and then I finally got to a part a place
where I was like oh I think these are
gonna be okay and then I thought to
myself what an arrogant bastard or
thinking oh now now your jokes are good
and yeah so it just took a little while
and that's free
yeah I imagine with something like that
you're it's never it's never totally
done like you could be fine-tuning it
for the rest of your life if you don't
just come yeah just looking at my hair
on camera I'm like better go back and
retake that there you go why don't I
wear that shirt yeah I'm happy with the
boots but the jeans come on what are you
trying to do you trying to look like a
22 year old let's troll yourself I do I
should I've reviewed myself a lot on
Amazon Prime yes have you do you
actually read the reviews of it after it
comes out I haven't not out of fear or
wanting to be adored which I do now only
I live a life of never completing
anything okay and just barely keeping up
so it's one of those things like god I
got to do that I well I'm kind of
exactly the same way that I in the past
have looked at comments a lot but mostly
for like crowdsourcing information or
ideas and that sort of thing and then
you always get caught up in like the
negative ones and sometimes you engaged
and sometimes you hate yourself for
engaging but I've done that less and
less but still the same like I should go
and just respond the comments like
that's always on my forever to do that I
just never do closet needs to be clean
yeah I need to reorganize yeah all day
know when Twitter when I first got on
Twitter I've always looked at the
comments and they did that all mean that
now is I don't know a minefield ten
years ago though but now I don't need
because there's such a jailbreak on the
comments that it doesn't yeah matter any
of you Anonymous hatred or adoration is
so I don't know it's
kind of like and now I don't care yeah
maybe it's cuz I'm old maybe it is maybe
that's the healthiest way to be yeah oh
yeah I don't yeah yeah I guess yeah I
get so many comments from my kids
anyways that yeah it's gonna say so you
have a son two sons two sons and wonder
how old are they
fourteen eleven so they're at the prime
age to judge you completely and yeah
they started that they got a jump start
on that years ago what do they think
about what you do do they think it's
cool are they embarrassed by it they if
I talk about they don't like it when I
talk about them but I have paid them if
I talk if I sometimes I'd be like I'd
like to tell this joke and they're like
alright well 200 bucks and all the money
you've raised entrepreneurs
yeah they've monetized my yeah they they
ya know they'll I guess they it's all
weights like I how did I I always
thought I was gonna be a businessman
because my dad always went to work in a
suit and tie so this is what I've always
kind of done right and it's something
they they also yeah it's we live I live
and so do you you live in a world where
you are with people that are known for
what they do and so so that that has
become strangely normal I'm not saying I
only hang out with famous people that
which I try to but or think people like
you just have because 70% of are the
people that you've worked with yes like
I would know all the plumbers if I was a
plumber right and seeing your friend
group and it's normal to them but any
other kid in any other state like this
is a very abnormal experience yeah I
would probably but it's not like I go
yeah but I don't even you died - I don't
know it's not they are very they were
very happy when I played in the
fortnight all the different for tonight
is the thing that they're most proud of
you for doing that I didn't horribly
embarrass them yeah while playing
fortnightly yeah so this was a public
fortnight
there it was a huge yes the tons of
charity money was given okay
a million bucks was given to the winner
to donate dang which shows you also that
Epic Games is doing just fine
yes popular video game in the history of
the planet I think they're okay but I
took them and they were like don't my my
old my older son was like look dad I'm
not the greatest at this game but you
are terrible
don't you are terrible at this game
don't mess it up okay no and then I
really for the I don't get nervous
anymore cuz I've been on stage so many
times yelling at drunk people that that
was one time I was like oh I'm nervous
and I'm operating a little tiny piece of
life and people can see if I'm good or
bad at this very clear delineation yeah
no I can't play it like I've tried I
it's just not I'm not my makeup it
doesn't I can't do it but it's never
been in your no I'm a Tetris girl so you
love detacher-- like puzzle games I like
simple I got a game for you I like Dave
& Buster's dumbass game was like those
are my jam okay yeah those give me a
giant like wheel that I hit a button and
it spins and I hope for 50 tickets oh
you would love hanging out with my 11
year old seems like we got a bunch of
prizes I was like you're right it only
cost me $200 now I call that casinos but
I do like how you can walk around with a
beard dave & buster's plainly that's oh
it's great I sew I lose everything
constantly but somehow I've kept - Dave
& Buster's power cards like the last two
years in my purse just in case because
you've got expire I'm fine and then have
you claimed the prizes
yeah I've claimed the prizes for the
night that I was there but these power
cards have like it was a night that's
like we got a stop because now we've
been here too long but there's still
money on these cards yes so I keep them
which maybe that's frugal maybe that's
psychotic I don't know it's probably a
little bit of those a little bit of both
and that's part of the charm right see
but when the society collapses yeah and
it's just rogue bands of marauders no
you're gonna whip
those that when they are like you're
dead we're going to put your head on a
pike and then you pull those two cards
out that's my my bunker is just gonna be
a Dave & Buster's I'm just driving
straight there and hoping for the best
hiding under a Jamie better get some
serious backup generators I assume they
have it they have everything was Dave
and who is Buster are we gonna get
something free out of talking about Dave
& Buster's this man this is I think me
manifesting it I'm really trying do you
get free stuff sent to you yeah like
unsolicited free things absolutely I
love it what's your oh okay cuz when I
came people I was like how dare you why
would you do that I'm like why not yeah
it's free okay so this gave a lot of it
away
I just remembered when I came in did the
soup years ago you were one of the
people that knew about the night cold
steel yes and you were obsessed with
cold steel and I hadn't met anyone else
that was like super obsessed with cold
steel and used head like katana blades
yes well I said if you have if you give
me some storage I will use them on
camera all the time are you still an
avid cold steel boy I do like cold steel
okay I don't know I haven't checked in
to see if there's still like a thriving
cold steel is a very thriving company
there in Ventura California yeah I think
it still he owns it you met him I don't
think I've met I know his name
because I dated a guy that bought the
DVD and brought it home and we watched
the full DVD with his roommate when I
lived in New York years and years ago of
its Lin just with a katana blade in a
gymnasium cutting a boot that has raw
meat inside and then you went to you
thought have I met the man of my dreams
or am I gonna run out before this red
flag or green flag I'm on the fence yeah
I bought a switchblade in Italy with
went while on my honeymoon
and I played with it the whole time and
my wife thought who what has happened
we're sitting there in Rome and look
click click just over it that was the
beginning it was like I have to say yes
to everything he suggested because she's
switchblade in Italy what's the coolest
thing that you've gotten for free oh man
or say weirdest thing Oh weirdest oh I
think the weirdest and yet useful was a
stool that goes around your toilet ok so
you don't sit on your toilet but you
squat over your toilet ok ok I'm trying
to imagine this it is a u-shaped stool
okay you stand on it and you squat so
instead of so yeah squatty potty yeah
that's I guess that's what it is
yeah you know you're supposed to sit
though at those no you're not oh maybe
I've been doing cuz I have a yeah you're
just legs are a little bit higher up
yeah because it's supposed to induce
like the actual like caveman like like
Jays men weren't sitting they were
squatting we don't know that for sure oh
yeah entire societies were like what do
we do first well we have to build a
chair that's the whole thing is that you
use these muscles that you net that's
why in China and numerous countries they
can squat forever because they've worked
those muscles and then supposedly it
stops you know well then I know cancer
from forming down there because you use
all the muscles sure I've been doing it
horribly wrong you just been sitting up
you just basically just been going in a
child's potty yes that's what your
simulate and it works
next time squat okay oh the actual name
of the product yeah yeah I guess that's
Annie okay that would be an easy up sees
yeah what if your needs were up here
what Matt change everything
what is the weirdest thing you've gotten
I see I paid for my squatty I used my
squatty potty no say matter one in my
bathroom right now you know the best
product that I've ever gotten for free
all along those same lines is poo pourri
I talked about it all the time
I think it's an ingenious product it's a
spray before you go and does it really
work I mean it creates an aroma that's
not so wretched but it does you know you
did now it smells like roses like a
little bit of like rancid rose now why
not I don't want to but I love it but
any for your product yes end it but why
not you know light a match before you
can do that that works but the poo
pourri to me especially like when you're
on sets and things like that oh yeah
when you don't have so many matches you
don't want a lot of sets that don't
allow them where everyone's just got
nervous shits all day long like you're
gonna run out of match it's real then
you get the reputations like there's
that pyromaniac grace helbig coming to
set again she's just gonna be lighting
matches all over the points bars just
stealing all their matches everywhere
yeah yeah but you got sent squatty potty
for free I'm very jealous of that a
wooden one what
no that's classy it was nice I broke it
so okay yeah so maybe you are supposed
to sit on this way that's not broke was
an intruder who is squatting no just got
real nervous about robbing yeah boy
we've talked I did we better get some
free stuff I hope so okay we're gonna
take a quick break real quick when we
get back I have more questions for you
and then we're to get into Twitter
questions which is always very telling
to me of how a guest is perceived by the
world right so hold on to your hat yeah
we'll be right back with more not Judy
[Music]
two deep support for today's show comes
from a company that's here to support
you that's right it's third love third
love designs bras with breast shape and
size in mind for a perfect fit and
premium feel hands down the most
comfortable bra that you'll ever own
they have straps that won't slip and tag
list labels and not to mention
lightweight super thin memory foam cups
that mold to your shape every customer
has 60 days to put their bra to the test
and if you don't love it you can return
it in third level wash and donate it to
a woman in need supporting charities in
their local San Francisco Bay Area and
across the United States I have a bunch
of third love bras and I truly truly
love them I wear sports bras most of my
life because I'm just you know lazy and
these truly are as comfortable as a
sports bra third love knows that there's
a perfect bra for everyone so they're
offering you guys 15% off your first
order go to third love comm slash grace
to find your perfect fitting bra and get
15% off your first purchase
that's third love comm slash grace for
15% off today as the creators of clean
beauty Bare Minerals is driven by a
philosophy that makeup and skincare
should make your skin better not just
better looking that's why their
best-selling original foundation is made
with only five ingredients and they're
all minerals for bare minerals to be
clean without compromise means good for
you skin formulas with proven
performance upgrade to clean beauty
products use the foundation finder at
bare minerals calm to find your perfect
match and get 20% off when you use the
promo code not too deep bare minerals
the power of good okay so I want to talk
a little bit about the special yes thank
you yeah how do you well so it's out by
the time this episode airs it have been
out and everyone can get it on and
rented on Amazon right yeah I think it's
now if you have Amazon Prime you can
just watch it sweet what is the like so
you go to a bunch of clubs yeah clubs
and you work out all this material and
then did you decide on the place that
you shot the actual special that was up
to the company and I always
negotiation okay you shut up in San
Francisco yes in San Jose because
there's a beautiful little theater there
that Charlie Chaplin has performed in
and I thought that would be I wanted to
go I was wanting to go to like Barrow
Alaska oh really but which is in the
Arctic Circle but then there was like
logistics and stuff and then my time and
get in there like just go this Sam yeah
and so then you what I I then I taped
like two are gonna say that we gonna did
four shows and every show was like 80 or
90 minutes long and then they cut it
down to 50 minutes that's nuts and the
lead-up to that I imagine is yes very
stressful obsessive-compulsive
workaholism really comes in handy when
you're a stand-up I'm sure what were
there any places that you played that
were particularly wonderful or
particularly terrible uh you know
nothing nothing was like really ever
really bad in Naples Florida was a very
strange mix of people okay and an
alarming number of elderly drunks really
really old really drunk and I think they
to the point where I was like what's
happening this is am I being pranked so
it became the drunkest weekend of now
and I've usually you can count on
Saturday night Late Show was always
pretty drunk yeah
Friday night Late Show starts drunk and
then they they've been working all day
and then they go to dinner then they go
to a late comedy show Hey and they've
been drinking and then they go holy crap
well for most sure I mean yeah around
the country
and then they go holy crap I'm tired and
then they fall asleep how are they but
but these were just consistent super
drunk a woman apt I mean not I mean this
is not a unique story but a woman
absolutely wet herself all over the
place It was as if she had like her
water had been yeah like she was going
for a record she had to be care it's
Rick I know that some comics have an
audience that is super drunk
show up drunk cuz it's a party and write
mine usually aren't like that not
because I've discouraged it or because I
think it's just but it's rare when
people are being carried out by all by
their limbs wow this woman was she
didn't know where she was and that's
just like this is gonna be I mean you
have to stop this with I mean most
comics do that but that you have to stop
mm-hmm everything right and wait for
them to clear it out yeah which it's
always fun for the momentum of that
you're trying to build cuz that I'd cost
that then I'm just going like no where
was I please someone remind me I was
talking about yes so that was I wouldn't
say it was like I've never I mean
there's some venues that don't have
bathrooms backstage like there's this
wonderful old theater in Virginia really
wonderful but it's grandfathered in
uh-huh
so you can't are you not grandfather but
UK it's a national it's on the
historical registry of Historic Registry
and so you can't change anything for
whatever reason or maybe they're lying
to me but they don't have a bathroom in
the back of the theater so my friend and
I and because I am like oh man do I have
time to run right the Mexican restaurant
across the street and then I don't
and then we pee in two cups we should
really give these away yeah I mean who
needs a merch table yeah you got to come
up with the alternative for that
[Music]
so yeah it's are you still on the road
now after the oh yeah I do a lot of
colleges so how's that I love it
really yeah I really it's very weird to
be doing comedy for people that
absolutely could be my children or
grandchildren at this point if I were
lived in the south but they they're
wonderful and everyone complaints about
kids being super PC and yeah they're
just for almost without exception
they've just been fun and wanting to see
comedy that's cool anyway were they
disappointed with
the number of people are like oh my mom
and dad loved you your mom and dad get
up there and be like enjoy the museum
this is a tribute show to old people
speaking of old people mmm
you are on Match Game yeah that's yeah
$100,000 pyramid oh well yes you can see
how I've been making my income since the
show's I was all more canceled I'll be
appearing on it how is that this is
what's what's alec baldwin's game night
that's match game match game okay you
know Hollywood game night NBC okay and
these are forgive me I haven't watched
these well you're a young person but I
you I grew up watching game show network
so I know all these games I know how
they work and I loved what like match
game I love oh we're gonna talk about
drag racing a little bit too snatch game
match game is obviously from the 70s
yeah it was brought back cuz
what's-his-face Charl who hosted it back
then uh now see I forget this is how
little sleep gene Rayburn yeah he was
fantastic he was great I mean now when
you watch it well it's he's a very good
host but it's thing with the family
favorite yes yeah there's a thing that
gene Rayburn did I hope his family's
listening know that when a new young
woman would appear on the show he was
like well it's your first time on the
show and you know what you have to do
for uncle gene we have a kiss and then
he would plant a really bad long kiss
and it was really be over the place oh
yeah that's exactly that's how Family
Feud be speaking a trash they were all
trashed as well all the saloons oh you
can see they're just like red-faced and
sweaty the whole time but the and then
of course you have richard dawson then
got family feud yes she then um enjoyed
so many moms across this country of ours
who would appear yeah my husband's
that's richard dawson and then there'd
always be a grandma it's like I want to
kiss ya very the new ones are for 2019
they are updated thank God yeah or is it
just celebrities competing or a match
game it is I mean yeah well you come up
with thee you help come up with the
answer right or the person for but like
pyramid is for you know you that's what
you actually have to match game match
game is a party time it's great fun and
alec is very good at it but michael
strahan is that one is hard you have to
come up you have to your timed and you
have to come up with the answers because
you're helping this person win actual
money you're up yes they're all but but
you have to work hard in this i think i
don't think i I think I'd be too nervous
about my abilities to perform under that
kind of pressure
dupa especially without one they they
make sure you know the game cuz we can't
go out there
yeah you can't go out there just
thinking like I kind of know how it
works so yeah cuz you're gonna screw
someone over and I we I got this we got
to the final pyramid we should we didn't
get a hundred grand but we got a lot of
money for this woman and she said to me
she was like if I win I'm going to jump
on you and she was like 6 1 and 1 and
then boy it's a good thing I do a lot of
potty squatting because I was ready are
you are you a game person like that like
do you play board games you do any of
that kind of stuff
I play a fortnight how dare you hi and
play video games and I play do you
really do play video games yes and I
play a lot of sports I if there is a
ball yeah no matter how its shaped I
grew up throwing it or running with it
we're hitting it you went to college for
something for some sort of athletics
well I went to college cuz I was
recruited to be a rower cool I got into
a fistfight with a rowing team with the
whole team varsity versus two freshmen
we lost so you got in a fistfight uh
yeah and the guy Jason Rainey the guy
who I
but we back-to-back fighting defending
ourselves to be a very successful lawyer
Microsoft I married a very good high
school friend of mine Suzanne Russell so
one down so after that Fiasco with the
rowing team the rowing team at the
University of Washington was it was I
don't know what it's like now but they
were peculiar and they had all these
rituals such as shaving the freshmen
would shave their head and eyebrows and
then put all that hair into a pillow and
then there was a display case of hair
pillows which is like a serial killer or
some sort of death camp
this was sounds like a cult that had a
pastime of rowing yes that's not I would
agree with what you very much so you
were part of a cult that just all
happened to enjoy refugee as a freshman
there's all these crazy stupid [ __ ]
rules and if you violated any of them
you would have to go throw yourself in
the lake
what and so you just go like all right
I'm going in the lake and guys would
come back soaked I was like what
happened like I didn't push a chair
improperly like it's November and
they're like yeah what do you do so this
is like a fraternity then yes oh I was
in a fraternity at that point and they
had nothing new they were very lacks
with full of football players and to
which they I am such a maniac that I was
they were like you should join the
football team I'm like sounds great and
I college yes and so I was on the
football team for two years so that see
I was assuming that people that play
because I went to college in my college
was so small we didn't have a football
team that I just assumed everything's
like Friday Night Lights like people get
recruited and they go like I didn't
decide to sign up for this was not a
normal path what I don't recommend it
yeah that was very dangerous but I was
you know like young yes I was in decent
shape so I I don't again I'm very lucky
that I am I'll I wasn't turned inside
out by some of these guys they were
they were insane athletes yeah I can
imagine
the so where how does getting into
entertainment fall in that part of your
life well you know people were cheering
for us performing these people they're
all at the game let's go this is great
give me a mic I was so bad in school
dyslexic continued to be and that I and
I got the bug for acting when I was a
fifth grader and that's all I ever
wanted to do and really and perform and
and so I did a bunch I also the only
other thing I was good at was sports and
so terrible in school I cheated through
every class Wow it was very good at
cheating it's really great when I go to
colleges yeah interviews because they're
like how was your college experience I
was like barely was there and I cheated
every time I was in class I mean these
are the foundations of a lot of
successful people this is why I'm
running for office see your way through
you're doing it okay are you a visco
girl I don't know okay just a voice do
you love scrunchies and hydro flasks
it's a very important hot-button issue
on the internet right now well it's a
real timely question with the scrunchies
yeah it's like grantees are back on
ironically back yeah it's there's this
whole whole trend I think now you'll see
this everywhere that I've mentioned this
cheese visco girl if you ask your sons
about it she's in here no none of us are
visco girl I am I am neutral I'm
Switzerland on it sometimes scrunchies
were horrible and then other times great
I mean that's very politically correct
I know it's politically correct but if I
it's just weird to me if people they
were okay member along well now it's
like 15 17 years ago when it was UGG
boots yeah well when I went to college
it was like ugg boots and leggings every
day and that was formal wear like that
was what you thought like you'd go to a
job interview yeah basically you would
turn you were turning into wall-e that
moved
yeah yeah with people Justin no but I
always like what you have UGG boots and
then women had miniskirts on it looked
like their house had caught fire and
they just ran out grab the grab the
first thing I got a miniskirt a mug
that's great yeah I mean that's kind of
what a visco girl looks like it's like
oversized t-shirts scrunchies hydro
flasks and like Birkenstocks
but the hydro flask why that specific
brand I don't I couldn't tell ya I'm
still learning as I go it's probably I
feel like I miss I mean I'm so old now
that that boat is trying to reconnect
your scrunchies no but when the next
college show that you do you'll really
connect with them girls yeah vsco which
stands for it's like an editing app on
your phone it's like the rifle to
Instagram I believe it's as much as I
can understand it it's the rival to
Instagram yeah how are they doing I have
no one knows but this is a being talked
about a lot in very vague ways so I
think you'll win a lot of favors if you
mention it good-evening visco girls
oh they lose their goddamn minds all
right yeah Central Washington University
there you go
okay we're gonna take one last break and
when we get back we have a bunch of
Twitter questions for you which is that
wasn't a Twitter question no that was
from my heart myself like what are we
gonna ask Joel oh I know number one is
he of visco girl I want to ask about his
family and his affinity for being the
dogs dogs go girls I'm restraining
myself I'm keeping talking about the
dogs cuz they're go I got some good I'll
show you a video during the break it's
gonna hurt my heart but yeah we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
- deep Warby Parker was founded with the
goal to create boutique quality eyewear
at a revolutionary price point the
glasses start at $95 including
prescription lenses and lenses include
anti glare and anti scratch coatings if
you need help you take the quiz at Warby
Parker comm slash Grace answer a few
questions and they'll suggest some great
looking glasses that are totally
personalized to fit your face and your
style with their free home trial program
you order five pairs of glasses and try
them on for five days and there's no
obligation to buy the glasses shipped
free and include a prepaid return
shipping label and now introducing Scout
by Warby Parker comfortable breathable
and affordable daily contact lenses
these lenses are made from a super moist
material that resists drying for lasting
hydration and comfort and you can wear
them for less than one dollar and 25
cents a day order a trial pack that
includes six days worth of contacts for
only $5 and then receive five dollars
off your next Warby Parker order my mom
is obsessed with her Warby Parker's I
have a bunch of friends that are
obsessed this company is chic they're
affordable and the try own process oh
you don't could deal with people staring
at you seeing what fits your face and
what doesn't oh it's dream order the
free home trial program or request a
trial of scout contact lenses for just
$5 by visiting Warby Parker comm slash
grace to learn more that's Warby Parker
comm slash Grace questions going to ask
you the two questions ask every single
guest Amaya
what girl disco girl that was a separate
but that might become a third question
um these I ask every single guests on
the podcast the first is who alive or
dead would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at boy I'd say Richard Gere
dead pass away and then I throw it out I
I stole that you okay well the other
question is to tell us your worst pant
shooting story or like a close call
worst yeah but as opposed to my best one
I mean people have different experiences
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so mine is college
jogging front lawn okay I'm gonna say
grace Helbig podcast there's a bathroom
right down the hallway we don't have
another your worst pants shooting
experience like I remember the best one
yeah that was a glorious day okay let's
get into these Twitter questions yeah
someone want to know what is your
favorite soup oh geez
yeah I'm saying actual soup uh you know
I like a stew okay yeah is that a soup I
gots liquid surrounded by the best soup
I don't know um yeah I don't know I
think yeah yeah that's real clever
question I've never heard that one
before did anyone actually respond
respond to to the Twitter questions yeah
these are all Twitter guys okay
everyone's asking how was it like being
a judge on drag race and if Miss
Michelle visage still hates you oh look
I watch it I'm a huge drag race fan i
watch that episode you were an [ __ ]
how dare you you were having a great
time and I was very complimentary you
were lots of Hudson holiday very happy
every time I was like those are a bunch
of dudes they yes Michelle I just mean
when I love my I love Michelle and we we
message each other
and I when she started getting annoyed I
was like oh this is my favorite thing
that's ever I feel like by the end of it
she was like turning the corner and like
oh I don't know
I may be optimistically she's she really
is
general genuinely delightful and a very
nice person but when that little game
can't kind of presented itself yeah that
I was annoying everyone I mean I can't
not go friend that I've just as long as
rue was happy than I was at right how
was the experience otherwise it was I'd
you know like exactly what you were
walking into yeah well I'd watched the
show a zillion times yes and this show
has become this it started out as kind
of very dirty like that show used to be
in sanely whole references work yeah and
now it's like a cultural phenomenon and
it's a great show obviously but I had a
great experience the most kind of
surprising thing that it was like a
nine-hour day because that costume
changes and the resets are major
well that's the crazy thing I think when
you watch the show that part of the show
happens so quickly compared to
everything else but you don't realize
that they're doing full like makeup
again just tear it all down and put it
all back yeah a whole different way and
then the amount of rehearsal time
they're putting in is astonishing yeah
the do you keep in touch with any of the
Queens I follow we follow a numerous
Queen on Instagram and Twitter and
there's been some there's been some what
he call it some direct messaging we had
what is her name she was on episode of
community well I'm really great so let's
just go with it was a drag queen okay I
mean I feel like you should show up a
drag Con I would if they they're like we
we're good uh
they asked if I could be on this
celebrity one and I was like I'm all-in
but I was working so I can do it
well I'm watching me dance would be a
pretty depressing or wonderfully
entertaining means yeah you just be like
to lip-synch for your life
so sad someone snow what's so bad about
having ice in your drinks I don't like
it hitting my teeth okay I don't like I
don't understand why people's drinks
need to be colder than the Arctic okay I
like a cold soda or as they say in other
parts of the country pop yep is great
but why dilute it with water look at the
ice product I don't want it to look I
don't that's why I like by the end of it
if you put ice in a coke by the end the
bottom of it it's just it's no longer
fizzy it's ridiculous and it needs to be
stopped
okay when I went to Europe and they
don't give you ice and everything if
they'll just give you a glass of cold
water I mean you're the this is why they
figured it out greatest place on the
planet someone just asked kedo question
mark I don't do that you don't do that
no have you dabbled in any of that type
of I tried the intermittent fasting
yeah how'd that go badly yeah I did it
for a while and I gained weight I'm sure
I wasn't doing it right but I would I
was absolutely a proselytising about it
and then I realizes my I was in my
bathroom with my wife and I was naked
what do you think she's like yeah you
know I don't do that keto I don't any
that's I just keep trying
I just basically keep track of calories
gotcha because I like just come from me
it's just simple math of output needs to
be less than input yeah keep it simple
okay otherwise I feel like everyone's
playing experiments with their bodies
well and then you're writing checks
thank you that you
cannot cash for the rest of you where is
like you're just gonna do this forever
you're just never gonna have a bowl of
pasta and every time you do you're like
well that's my wife we also live in this
society we we are obscene like we
everyone talks it was like well you were
in a real bad way these days I was like
I don't know we're obsessed with dieting
we can't seem to not eat good food
everywhere anyway go ahead go ahead know
that I think you're right that I haven't
it's just become all of a sudden I feel
like it snuck up on us like that even
though it's been around forever but
everyone's kedo now and everyone's
checking if they're in ketosis yes
they're all just that everyone's
obsessed with it pee on a stick to check
if you're in ketosis kills me that I'm
like so everyone that's saying that
during keto is at one point during the
day like at home pissed
imagine the plumber who has to service
the equinox those [ __ ] sticks are in
there jammed it the whole thing yeah
everyone's pregnant here or everyone's
doing ketosis yeah you know a person
that injects themself to make it like
they're pregnant what fun what do you do
grace I do try to live in moderation
balance the same sort of thing you
exercise obviously yes I run for a day I
don't do it a day I have a treadmill and
usually for like stress management and
like anxiety and that kind of thing it's
my I get stressed out enough that you
have to run and not be around anyone
that's a really great like fitness
program oh yeah it hasn't caught on like
she pretend you're running away from
something yeah in in in place in my home
it's my I allow myself to use my
imagination and it really creates a real
solid foundation he's got a knife yeah I
have a green screen behind me that I
project a lot of like horrible images on
see that that works really well I'm
right in the book okay if Joe had to
pick one childhood memory that he could
relive as an adult what would it be I
mean it doesn't sound like hair pillows
it's one of them
no I'm he's a child boy relive it yeah
like now like recreated like I would be
charged either way you can go back and I
mean you can't order a my going back in
time yeah yeah maybe like you can go
back and be like whatever the nice
memory was you can go back and like live
that out for a second feel that goodness
I feel like I could visit you're
resisting wanting to I just feel like I
can remember that time and go that was
really great yeah maybe someones just
asking what was your favorite childhood
memory it isn't easy because if you go
back in time and are put back into your
I don't know eight year old body and I
know it you have been being forced to
relive this memory I have no choice
alright so what was your one of your
happiest childhood memories that comes
to mind I did well this is a general one
when scrunchies no I remember thinking
when I was eight years old
I remember my friend Spencer Looney and
I Spencer Looney great name loose in
Hawaii he he and I remember him like we
were both eight and when I was like I
think we're at the perfect age
we were like this is perfect we're so
we're so happy we're like for whatever
reason were like this perfect date you
both agreed on it yeah I remember when I
turned nine I was like well it's no way
it's all downhill from here we really
peaked okay here's the last question I
asked him about the Seahawks yeah what's
your question about the Seahawks didn't
you get to announce a gamer's I
announced the game and this is a team
you obviously like you don't hate them
yeah I'd be weird if I would be like let
me go announce this I'm gonna announce
the Patriots game they're from these
jerks they'd always win see I would
listen to that
that's probably yeah yes it was a dream
come I could not believe I was
announcing for the seat so how do you
even prep for that well you could study
the 90 dudes that were on the team at
that point there it was still a
preseason game so it was very good
they're not having me on in important
games but see it was in its all nearly
impossible but some people can but could
keep track of that many people I can't I
mean I knew the starters and things like
that so what I did was I what we're also
in charger in the Chargers temporary
home which is a soccer stadium in Carson
which has very few seats compared to
most so it's a very unique place to
watch a game and Steve rebel who was on
the team is the Seahawks announcer and
announced their Super Bowl wins and
things like that and so he's a legend in
Seattle so I spent most of the time
asking him questions and he told an
incredible story when he was on the team
he goes well there's they now they use
real sticky gloves to catch the ball
then they used to not have those they
would just taste this stickum and put it
on their hands hey which became a
problem because then it would get on the
ball and the quarterback wouldn't be
able to throw the ball very well but
this one dude on the team just slathered
himself in the sticky stuff and he said
he practically could catch the ball
without using his hands I would just
stick to it but then this was the
sentence he said he goes during halftime
while he was smoking a cigarette he set
himself on fire and because the stuff
was super flammable let me get this
straight
just a player just a human torch being a
fan like just seeing Billy
self-immolated I was unhappy with his
play oh my god
well that's amazing what a beautiful
image well my family is Eagles to South
Jersey at home I'd lived in Haddonfield
New Jersey for two years as a child
right side of Cherry Hill yep
that's where I live Haddonfield was my I
went to Gateway and Haddonfield was our
tennis rivalries were you on the tennis
team I was I was not good at it my
participates how they asked you back to
your high school
not that I know no no I you've got a
publicist obviously I don't want to go
back are you you're not you're not old
enough for your Union at this point
oh yeah it's got a come and gone and I
did not participate cuz our we had like
our student president for whatever
reason was in charge like we nominated
like the drug addict funny kid for our
students was like a very I remember I
don't do Facebook anymore but at that
point there was like a very half-hearted
like we're going to the diner if anyone
wants to come that's unfair when you
elect a class president senior year and
then like well you know you have to plan
the reunion in ten years you might as
well go like you have to build a
spaceship in the next 10 years you're
like oh it sounds great yeah to a 17
year old that just goes sure I'll deal
with that 10 years got it
Joel thank you for being here you know
this fortune cookie earlier and every
guest that makes time for being on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie from us to you so this is a
personalized yes it is you can open it
and and take a look at oh I'm not gonna
open it here okay great wait all right
here we go okay I know it's really long
yeah sorry boy we think they're short
every time [ __ ] you Jim okay
beanbag was a literal beanbag in a past
life in an apartment shared by five male
college students life is rough our uff
yeah um you know my fortune for this is
whoever wrote this will be sent to
writer jail will never be allowed back
out we wanted to leave you with life is
rough
I'm gonna tell beam back I'm not gonna
tell the other dogs we're not mentioned
yeah but they weren't the star of this I
will say this about being back one last
anecdote he is the greatest cuddler huh
you've ever met so if you are you happen
to be asleep near him when you're him no
if you were asleep and you're just kind
of on your back he will find a way to
get near you he will put his head in
between like a neck your chin and your
chest and press himself down on your
neck you and you'll be like this is so
sweet I'm dying but it's so sweet and
then if you move it all just slam it
right there oh and my ironically the
dogs love my wife more than anyone they
stay follow her around like she is st.
Francis I will just highly suggest more
dog content on the Instagram I think the
world needs it I think I might put up
that refrigerator one soon please where
can people find everything that you're
doing if they don't already know where
can they get the specialist go to I
don't know go to well you're at Joel
McHale Atlantis calm resort no let's see
yeah go to add me I'm at Joel McHale
calm and then the special is on Amazon
Prime and you should definitely download
that it's called live from Pyongyang
which I've already tricked a couple
people into thinking that I actually
went to North Korea to tape it which I
said you know that's not really possible
more like why not now I don't want to
get into it now but but yeah so go do
that thank you for making time thank you
appreciate it
super so super alright we'll see you
guys next time on another episode of not
too deep goodbye yeah 2deep 2deep 2deep
2deep was crazy back not too deep as a
production of grace Helbig incorporated
producer Melissa D months camera
operator Katrina Henning edited by
Shireen Lana unis post production sound
bike
Chris Henry and an extra special thanks
to Flula for the theme music
[Music]